sophie turner is thankful for her fiance
Joe Jonas
[Music]
yep it's clear the soon-to-be married
couple are suckers for each other but it
wasn't always bliss Sophie admits before
meeting her man she was at a low point
in her life and Joe helped her in a big
way in a new cover story for Glamour UK
the Game of Thrones star gets real about
experiencing what she calls an identity
crisis and Joe is a key part in helping
her find herself she told the mad quote
I think for the longest time I didn't
have a real sense of myself I had a bit
of an identity crisis where I was
playing all these people and I'd grown
up faster than I probably should have
done I kept thinking Who am I of course
now they're engaged the actress says
that Joe has been a huge part in pushing
her to find her happiness outside of her
career that just said makes my heart
smile no I love that and he popped the
question in October 2017 and she gushed
about how he's changed her world for the
better
quote a lot of my happiness now is to do
with being with a person I've fallen in
love with who loves me more than he
loves himself and who wants to see me
find my own happiness it's really great
to see them talking about each other
more because they're notoriously really
private now Sophie opened up to UK
Sunday Times in July and hinted a little
bit about their relationship she said
this I very much isolated myself for a
while and for God what was fun going out
with friends going out to eat not really
having a care and people I've met
recently in my life have drawn me out of
that that's something that each he
actually kind of saw firsthand when we
asked Sophie about Joe before they were
engaged check this out I've got a know
is Joe rooting for Sansa to end up on
the Iron Throne I don't know I don't
know we didn't talk about it we loved
blush
yeah or I'm sweaty I can tell she seems
to be in a more positive place since her
identity crisis and Joe talked about
their wedding on The Late Late Show with
James Corden recently guys it's really
cute we're getting married this year
yeah we're gonna have a summer wedding
nice Joe Nick and Kevin Jonas also got
hooked up to a lie detector test during
their carpool karaoke James Corden put
Joe in the hot seat with this question
do any of your brother's wives get on
your nerves no boy I mean no lie the
ladies all like each other too doesn't
mean that brothers have to get along all
the time
Sophie is already considered one third
of the Jay sisters the cute nickname of
course is because they are jonas
brothers significant others and she now
seems to have a built-in sisterhood they
all started together in the sucker music
video which was epic this was of course
the Jonas Brothers first song in six
years but I kind of think the ladies
stole the show
[Music]
I'm super here for Joe and Sophie
they're so cute and they seem like such
a sweet couple that really supports each
other and it is giving me those
feel-good absolutely of course we'll
keep you updated with all the latest
cute Hollywood couples so be sure to
subscribe to all things et in the
meantime I'm Courtney teza know and I'm
Hallie Stevens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]